all right thanks very much it's great to
have this whole panel here that we can
we can hear from you know in the
Canadian context it's always a special
event we can bring together a bunch of
people from Montreal together with a
bunch of people from Alberta so
hopefully we'll Forge national unity
here we I guess you know by way of
introduction I'm given the the scope
here to say a couple of words of thanks
I mean I'd like to just thank CFR for
you know all of these three rounds of
fellows announcements which I think we
all feel has done a lot for a I research
in Canada and particularly for having
the foresight to also have the
affiliates program beyond the three
Institute's which because our
affiliations are being given as the
three institutes might not be entirely
obvious to those of you in the audience
who who aren't watching how the sausage
is made here but those of us said
Waterloo and Dalhousie and Guelph and
UBC and SF you really value these
contributions as well and and also I
think we really would be remiss not to
acknowledge the contributions that Ensor
and other Canadian funding organizations
throughout the years have made in
support of AI research so it's great to
see Canadian AI research drawing a crowd
like this it's fantastic I'm turning to
our illustrious panel here it hasn't
escaped my attention that this is the
yet another panel in the same format as
a panel that you guys have seen before
so I'm gonna do my best to just mix
things up a little bit to keep it
interesting so I'm gonna begin by asking
our panelists to introduce themselves as
we've done before and then I'll turn to
some questions in sort of the same vein
that we've heard but but maybe with a
little bit of a different perspective so
let's just take it from the panelists in
the order they're seated any good mean
hi everybody my name is Eva I'm an
assistant professor at McGill University
and I'll be part of Mila I mainly work
on building conversational mod
conversation yeh models for
different tasks different devices and
different languages that's only
practical side but on the theoretical
side I'm interested in finding out what
are the fundamental representations of
language that facilitate building
conversational models and I'm also
interested in problems like biases when
we build language models what kind of
biases creep into the models and how
does it have effect on conversation
models I am Tim O'Donnell I'm a
professor at McGill also famila I'm a
little bit of maybe have a different
background and many people here today
I'm a cognitive scientists and a
linguist my primary appointments in the
Linguistics department at McGill and my
PhD is actually in psychology so I'm
very interested in computational models
of cognition especially language
cognition although I've worked on other
areas most recently I've been very
interested in the problem of
compositionality so the fundamental
feature of language is that it's a map
from form to meaning that's
compositional meaning the meaning of
holes like sentences is built out of the
meaning of the parts and I've worked on
identifying the basic units there on the
form side in speech and text in sign and
mapping those into semantic
representations
I am Aishwarya Roy I am currently a
research scientist at deep mind I
graduated from Georgia Tech earlier this
year and I will be joining Mila and
University of Montreal next fall so
speaking of research my general
interests are at the intersection of
computer vision natural language
processing and deep learning but more
specifically I am interested in this
problem called visual question-answering
BQE where basically the idea is that we
want to build machines that can answer
natural language questions about images
so for instance I could take a picture
of this room and ask what kind of event
is this how many people are here and so
on there are variety of reasons why I am
interested
this particular problem from different
perspectives so it feels very natural to
be testing visual understanding of a
system by asking questions in natural
language just as you would test kids
understanding about a particular subject
area be purely from an application point
of view I think vqi can have useful
applications such as serving as an aid
for visually impaired users so they
could ask questions like is it safe to
cross this way it could also be used for
building interactive demos for children
so for example they could ask what
animal is this where this is found and
it could also be used as interactive
assistance for humans and lastly images
one of my favorites is from a research
point of view that this problem of vqa
involves interesting research challenges
the problem of fish will the cognition
natural language understanding and
understanding about common sense and
knowledge bases so I would like to give
a very quick example just to highlight
the degree of the challenges in the
problem so for instance let's say the
question is what is the person in the
blue shirt holding and the machine is
given a picture where is a person who
shared holding something right so it
seems like a trivial question that a kid
might be able to answer but let's
imagine what it takes for a machine to
be able to get to the right answer so it
has to figure out the person in the blue
shirt in the image this is called a
problem of language grounding and then
after that it has to understand what it
means by holding that it needs to look
at the object in the hands of the person
and hands are not even mentioned in the
question so in some sense this is common
sense understanding and once it has it
is looking at the hand so it needs to
identify that object which is the
problem of visual recognition the story
is not over yet most of these models are
trained on large data sets consisting of
images questions and answers but what if
most of the people tend to be holding
briefcases in the data set then the
machines tend to memorize that oh let's
see let's say briefcase is the answer so
we need to train machines to overcome
such kind of vices so yeah that's why
I'm interested in vqf hello
you hear me okay hello everyone I'm
sorry Chandler I'll be starting as an
assistant professor at Polytechnic
Montreal and I'll be associated with
Mila I work in the intersection of deep
learning reinforcement learning and
natural language processing some of the
research questions that I'm interested
in includes how can we design algorithms
which can model really long term
dependencies that arise in like various
reinforcement learning and NLP problems
this involves tackling challenges like
vanishing and exploring gradients that
there arise when you want to train
architectures with really long sequences
I'm also interested in designing
continual learning systems which like
would not have any catastrophic
forgetting issues and this includes
research in the directions of how can we
design modular neural architectures
where there is less interference between
the modules on how can we design memory
augmented architectures which would have
a long term memory which would help us
remember things in a continued learning
setting I'm also interested in multi
agent reinforcement learning
oh I'm Bebo and I'm a new assistant
professor at the University of Alberta
also affiliated with Mila
and actually from AV sorry for that
we're building bridges already okay so
my research is mainly a natural arch
processing and with machine learning
methods and the long term goal of NLP is
of course teacher machine to understand
and communicate with humans or using
natural language but the short term
short term goal of my research is
sometimes come natural language
understanding or with a little bit
symbolic reasoning for example or
you-tube sentence classification then
you want to make sure where is the
evidence
like which word or maybe in a paragraph
which sentence talks about some
information this is this is a kind of
you know toy example of reasoning
another example is maybe you'd also do
sentences okay
then what is the synthetic structure of
the sentence so we know natural language
has synthetic structures the syntax
trees but can the computer reason about
the syntax tree by itself in an
unsupervised way so these are some
symbolic reasoning or some reasoning
part underline the understanding problem
and the techniques we use is typically
reinforcement learning and other
relaxation for other kinds of relaxation
for reinforcement learning and the other
part of my research is sentence
generation with applications like
summarization or paraphrase generation
or whatever and we also use
reinforcement learning and also
searching algorithms to do that so for
me my name is Adam and I am from Amy and
imma stay there yeah so I'm at Amy and
at the University of Alberta and I'm
also one of these really lucky people
that has a split position so I'm also at
Diamond Albert as well so get to mix the
academic life and the industrial life is
really really nice
so I was gonna tell you that work on
reinforcement learning but see fires
decided I wasn't on that panel so I
guess I'll do a switch up here and just
do something else that was key yeah
so it's already been mentioned I work on
continual learning I also like to call
it lifelong learning because I like to
evoke the idea that an agent's actually
learning from a lifetime experience
right it's not the short horizon thing
it's not iterative attempts on games
there's just one trajectory that the
agent gets to learn from so things like
you know having multiple copies of the
environment or building in a lot of
domain knowledge that might not be so
successful and so that immediately leads
to research questions like you know how
do you represent knowledge in the
learning system how do you how do you
build models of the world how do you
plan with those models especially when
you know when you think about this
problem setting we often imagine that
our learning agents are huge they're
massive right like our tardy agents are
way way bigger than the game emulator
but in actuality it's like the opposite
of that right like our agents are tiny
our computational resources are tiny
compared to the vastness of the learning
problem and so you have to start
thinking about how do you deal with
approximation how do you
with models that are gonna be wrong
they're gonna be inaccurate and how do
you build representations of the world
you know especially dealing with these
temporal effects you need to member
remember things way in the past so
usually I'm inspired by robotics and
everyone swallow I'll go in and do work
in robotics and then get really
frustrated and said and then I'll come
back down where the research and I and
that's kind of a good pivot point to go
back and forth to touch reality see the
real problems and then inspire your
research so Sarah Connor thanks
okay so we've typically been asking
panels to offer advice to other
researchers I want to mix that up a
little bit and given the audience you've
got here I think this is a chance for
everyone to learn from you so so I want
to ask you to reflect on some advice
that you might be able to offer other
researchers outside your own
specialization that comes from some kind
of technical idea in your own field so
we're lucky that we have a really
methodologically diverse panel here so I
think we have some reason to expect that
you might have very different insights
to offer so I wonder can you think of a
cool technical idea a recent
breakthrough a persistent challenge in
your field that you think should be more
broadly understood by the AI community
and might might be useful for people to
understand let's take this one in in
random order since I'm taking you by
surprise so let's let's see if any of
you have had something to say about this
go for it so in 20 end of 2018 we
created a data set called conversational
person answering and with the hope that
this is one of the most difficult
datasets so the the task involves you
are given a paragraph and then you're
having a conversation with this machine
so something like how where is the c4
meeting happening Bank [ __ ] and then
what else is is there what else is there
means what else is there in Vancouver
without having to specify in Bangor and
Utah like this is one of the very
challenging problems because the machine
has to endure
and not just language but also
conversational history and then this
model which everybody know bird came out
which is an unsupervised free training
model where you're trying to predict
missing word in the context and the
human performance was around 88 or 90
and and the models within within the
span of three months we had best perform
models at the at 88 to 98 and now the
models are beating human performance so
it's fascinating that this model can
just go through the whole text without
even seeing what the world is just like
reading lot of text and being able to do
this task so that fascinates me what is
that this model knows about the world
without even seeing the world so that's
one thing I wish somebody has an answer
to thanks very much Adam it looked like
you had something to say as well yes so
so you're asking for like something we
need to work on more perhaps yeah I
guess I'm asking in particular for sort
of a technical take away something that
you're excited about or that you think
others might be able to build on or take
something from well I mean I guess the
first thing I jumped in mind is that you
know one of the reasons we're all here
is just to work on you know
generalizable learning systems and I
think that's one of the biggest
limitations of current machine learning
systems is that they don't know how to
generalize and so specifically in the
context of reinforced learning you know
we have our Atari suite we have games
with paddles that you bounce balls off
the paddles and then if you train on one
of those games like breakout and then
you go to pong it doesn't work and so it
just seems like this is the biggest
thing we need to work on and it's it's
just the eminent challenge right now
yeah you're answering my next question I
did see there was a financier but for
the rest of the panelists I really want
to in this question here about something
that currently exists that you know your
field is currently doing well that you
think might not be adequately understood
outside your kind of narrow sub area
particularly
because it maybe it's something very
recent that you know you think it's
interesting for the rest of the room to
hear about and Adam if you want to weigh
in later on that as well I feel free but
in the meantime Lily did you something
what did you say oh I'm not sure whether
I understand the question completely but
I think the thing really working well in
LG recently is the large scale
preachment model like birds or GPT to
whatever so they are really working well
amazing performance in almost all NLP
tasks but then the problem is like the
NLP research degrades to such as an
arrow that you just taking the model and
you'll fine tune a little bit and then
you publish a new paper so in this sense
I can publish infinite amount of paper
because identify infinite numbers of
tasks and create infinite numbers of
this as to that so I think this is what
is working really well but it looks like
unsatisfactory scientific research then
I think we shall be thinking about what
is more scientific behind that and I
think one of the main challenge in NLP
is the modeling of semantics so this is
the question about the question
Randi as in the morning I can't find
Randy it's Randy okay
anyhow but this is the real challenge of
NLP research and I think it should be
addressed more in the future work yeah
go ahead
yeah I think I'd like to expand on this
so I don't know if I know of any very
new things from my field that are
applicable but I know of some very old
things so I think and I'm very impressed
by these contextualized board embeddings
we're using them for everything these
days but they still often fail to
generalize in systematic ways very
simple permutations of argument
structure for instance in sentences they
can't detect or they miss generalize
based on this now I'm the linguistic
side of course we've had no theory of
word meaning turned it historically of
specific words but we have a theory of
glue for how word meaning is assembled
in
more complicated structures like the
meaning of sentences discourses etc so a
lot of these tools I think can be
incorporated into deep learning systems
and are starting to be in fact across
the board so we have a bunch of projects
on you know using ideas about variable
binding and logics and this kind of
thing in with in differentiable settings
but I think actually just there could be
much more of this the the literature is
a little bit unapproachable but I think
some of us are starting to form bridges
and this is where I see a lot of
progress that could potentially be made
thanks I guess our two remaining
speakers in the middle one of you want
to go I would like to actually follow up
on what Adam was saying about
generalization so based on my
experiences in the domain of visual
question-answering
we found that you be the traditional
paradigm is training and testing your
models on iid distributions but we try
when you change the test distribution
while making sure that the data the
input have sufficient information to be
able to get to the answer but it's just
that the overall distribution looks
different from 20 models fail and it's
just that I would like to see more of
out of distribution testing thank you
okay so I work like in both reckon
neural networks and reinforcement
learning so my observation is like there
has been like significant improvements
in terms of designing better recurrent
architectures but in if you consider
reinforcement learning like so so we do
a lot of research on the algorithmic
sites of reinforcement learning but I
feel like there is a lot that could be
done in the intersection of these two
like where like you take the
architectural biases and introduce those
to the algorithms like this is more like
having explicit parameterization of your
agents which is going to help us in like
learning better right like so so instead
of like having all the effort in the
algorithmic side like so
you can we can also have like move away
some efforts to the architectural bias
of the algorithm
so it sounds like for the most part you
guys are thinking about sort of encoding
past knowledge in in retro ways both
about kind of semantic structures and
about kind of algorithmic designs sounds
like you guys are very excited about
contextual language models but you feel
like their understanding is kind of
superficial and it's not the
collaboration tolerance is another kind
of theme that came up across what many
of you guys had to say any other
reactions said to that or to what you
heard from the other panelists about
this but let's move forward then to
thinking in a more future-looking way so
let me ask you I'm five years from now
what research challenges do you think
that your fields will have substantially
solved that they haven't solved today
and what new areas of focus do you think
your fields will be aiming at you know
that are substantially different from
that the current focuses today and and
if neither of those two questions takes
your fancy let me give you one more
which is what what problems do you think
will be de-emphasized by your fields
what what possible blind alleys do you
think that your field might might
recognize you know isn't worth the focus
that's being given to it today and once
again I'll let you guys jump in unless
unless nobody goes first I have some
Parts I think based on how the field is
moving right now it feels like there is
a lot of interest in moving from
supervised learning on static data sets
to more interactive environments and
also towards unsupervised learning so I
think five years from now we are already
hill-climbing a lot on static data sets
and five years from now we would have
very good performances on standard
benchmarks and we would have I think
also made some progress in interactive
learning and unsupervised learning I
have some thoughts so I think in the
last five to ten years like we have made
significant progress in single task
learning so and very recently like we
have been
a lot on the multitask learning setting
so so learning just one task from
scratch is like I would not say it's
solved but like we have understood the
problem recently but there is not much
understanding in a multitask setting so
this involves things like transfer
learning or like meta learning or
learning to learn I would like I would
expect to see a lot of progress in these
multitask settings in the next five
years I think as mentioned one of the
challenge in NLP is how to model the
semantics or how to let the machine to
do reasoning and I think this could be
or one of the breakthrough in maybe next
few years and the current approach I'm
taking is to do to design a mechanism
that allows the network to do symbolic
reasoning just like as mentioned if you
want to do paragraphs paragraph
classification you can say maybe the
classification is based on this and and
so that sentence then the network has to
be very or has to be very serious like
where is the evidence so that you can
make the classification and also the
example I mention is synthetic reasoning
for the sentence modeling so current
approach is very ad hoc you see for each
task we define the reasoning mechanism
and and let the model to do reasoning in
under this mechanism but maybe in the
future we can have a more generic
reasoning mechanism for different NLP
tasks but in a more symbolic way that
you just put a large black box machinery
that is good especially for industrial
applications but what is the scientific
point behind that so I think there could
be some work tools in the next few years
so another thing we might solve and I'm
guessing it's me is long text
understanding so right now all this all
the conversation models are person
answering models given some limited
context they can really do well but like
say I gave
textbook and I asked you a random
question from the textbook can you still
answer the question like that we are not
there yet but my guess is we will be
there but what where we want where we
may not be there is can we make models
be creative like humans so that's
creativity requires even more
intelligence we might be able to mimic
it and fool people but I guess it
requires much more like something like
telling a joke I think we're gonna
probably be working less on games and
simulators in five years so you know the
earlier panel there was three people
talking about advanced robotics
hopefully that would be five or six in
five years because I really think that's
where things are going I really think
that's where the cutting edge of where
our algorithms break down I mean you see
this there's been tons of gains in in
you know online applications and video
games and all kinds of things but
robotics still resists because things
are non-stationary it's really noisy
it's high dimensional that it's just
really challenging problems to work on
and I think I think that's what we're
gonna go yeah so I actually so I'm gonna
say something a bit more sort of
abstract here I have the feeling that
one of the problems we have with
identifying where our systems fail to be
compositional now is that we don't
actually have a good operationalize
working the definition of what
compositionality means so on one hand we
have like very classical systems that
are you know purely symbolic and
combinatorial and we say it's something
maybe kind of like that but obviously
this is not where natural language
exactly lives in some sort of
compositionality spectrum and I I've
seen a couple there's some work we're
doing and I've seen a couple of other
threads that have emerged recently some
in psycholinguistics
looking at representations of say
dependency structure in terms of
information theoretic wants
tee's and some interpretation of things
like contextualized word embeddings in
terms of similar quantities that make me
think that actually we're moving towards
a place where we're going to have a
general sort of information theoretic
way of measuring things like
compositionality I think this is going
to lead to say new kinds of
regularization new kinds of objectives
that let us pick the level of
compositionality we want in a particular
system reflect in a coding theoretic
kind of way cool any reflections on each
other's comments from the rest of you
you're such a sedate panel he's supposed
to be like viciously disagreeing with
each other
if not then let me let me ask you a
question about Canada so so you've
obviously you know all chosen to be
working in AI in Canada as some of you
spanning industry and academia and what
what do you think are the strengths and
weaknesses of the Canadian AI system
what what what has drawn you to Canada
and what do you think is really working
well here and conversely what do you
think Canada should be focusing on to
take it to the next level in the AI
space let's let's go backwards from from
a dimension yes so I can only really
speak about you know Alberta and Amy
because that's that's where I am but you
know I I went to school in the East
Coast and I came Bellbird and it was
really obvious right away that it was an
amazing place to be a student there was
there was good research funding there
was amazing minds there and it's just
the best place in the world to be a
student reinforced learning in my
opinion and then you know so I graduate
and I went to the US for a while and I
just I get a little bit of experience of
what the funding model was like down
there and and how the student
interaction worked and it was very much
students were assigned to big projects
and then people felt very attached to
students they had funded and students
could have move around a lot and and
also it was just the the academic
experience there it just wasn't the same
you know I was just used to a room full
of piercing questions and and and
stimulating conversations and so coming
back I also realized that it was also
the best place in the world to be a
researcher in reinforced learning not
just a student and so you know that's
kind of the strengths you know amazing
students
amazing freedom to do research great
funding model you know the weaknesses
are you know it's it's uncertain climate
right now especially with climate change
and with the way that the economy is
going and there's there's gonna be a
real hard push for us to deliver on a
lot of the promises and the excitement
in machine learning and if we don't
we're not gonna be immune here right so
we do have to take this job series that
we have to convince our funders and we
also just have to do a good job of
showing their research has value in the
long run okay so I got my degree in Peak
University in China and then I worked as
a postdoc in Waterloo with Pascoe papad
is Pascal here no okay so you can say
whatever you want
oh yeah so that's why I come to Canada
and I find it's a really good place for
for research also during my postdoc you
know it's very flexible just just like
as Adam mentioned oh I'm not I was not
bounded to any particular project I can
work with or whatever who I work want to
work on or what I want to work on and
and then I joined UFA as a faculty
member the funding model seems work well
like I have abundant funds and also I
can do work on whatever I think
important to NOP research or AI research
so that's why I think it's a great
opportunity for me to stay here yeah so
I haven't I haven't realized all those
challenges like the Canadian economic oh
I know I noticed something yeah one by
face the Oberto in those situations
going worse if the government is kind of
in the winter right okay yeah it's kind
of a winter but yeah so I'm not a
citizen ofc ourse oh I I just hold open
it like so I am not to rely
about those days yes to redirect this
question a bit for everyone still to
come many of you have experience in
countries besides Canada so it might
also be interesting to reflect on you
know the Canadian strengths and weakness
in the context of the other systems that
you've been part of so compared with
China I think Canada is obviously gives
the more flexible way of doing research
like you can work on the real problem
and you don't have to come to many
papers and also you don't care too much
about the values I mean obviously we
publish good papers but not specifically
in the shortlist of like top-tier
conferences and it gives us a very good
environment to do research that we
really care about Thanks
that's right so in my case like I did my
PhD at the University of Montreal and
milla so I liked the research every
Raman there's so much that like I
decided to stay in Vila so what I like
about research and like machine learning
research in Montreal is is that there is
actually a very fine line between like
the research in industry and academia
like so there's a strong collaboration
that exists between industry and
academia which i think is like a very
unique plus for for Mila apart from that
like so like we have also developed this
critical mass of machine learning
researchers in these three institutes
which is kind of missing in several
other places in different countries so
so this gives us like a really vibrant
research environment to do like good
machine learning research in terms of
weakness I would just say the Quebec
immigration is not that friendly enough
to attract more talents so so that's the
weakness
right so in terms of things that are
unique in Canada I think as Seth was
mentioning it's the vibrant ecosystem
over there great people great research
directions being pursued a lot of
support from government and institutions
for long term research and as Sarah
pointed out something that I feel is bit
unique about Canada is this healthy
collaborative ecosystem between
industries and universities regarding
the things that could be improved as I
think Canada already gets a lot of good
students but if maybe it can be pushed a
bit more towards like if to compete with
places like MIT CMU but I think that
might already happen naturally over a
few years as more and more interesting
research comes out of Canada
thanks well let's see I moved up here
from the states about three years ago
and I'd have to say that the the funding
system up here is way easier it's way
better I think it fosters a real
diversity since more people it's easier
to get funding for in smaller amounts
for more people it really fosters a
great greater diversity of intellectual
progress and I think this is a really
really strong thing and Montreal in
particular right now it's there's just
an overwhelming amount going on so I
moved I was at MIT before I think
there's quite a bit more going on in
Montreal right now then there you know
this is by far the most intensity I've
seen anywhere in terms of negatives I
think that right now things are very
chaotic because of all this growth all
this sudden growth right now and so this
is not necessarily necessarily a
negative but I think well it remains to
be seen how everything kind of settles
down and what kinds of institutional
structures can be built to sort of
channel all this energy and and you know
activity that's going on thanks sorry TV
last night do you yeah I did my PhD in
the UK and in Edinburgh and then I moved
to pour the postdoc at Stanford
so comparing the academic scenario like
this is Canada is new to me but even in
my little experience so I felt like UK
has a very rigid academic structure
really all Cambridge C 1800 style
probably and the salaries are terrible
and coming to us
I find the research is really cutting
edge and but then there is this like
constant fight for funding who also only
few places get might get all the funding
whereas in Canada I really like that all
my colleagues will get funding including
me so even though it's little I really
like that apart from that I see the
diversity here other countries right now
the political situation is not better
like I see a lot of Iranians a lot of
Indians a lot of Pakistanis everywhere
that kind of community is here whereas
in the state's it's not that much but
the most important thing that attracted
me here is Ivy stood all these
universities and also McGill but I went
to Miller and the co system there like
that was my final patient point okay I'm
going going to come here the reason is
like within like 10 feet distance you
have all these companies and if you want
to do public service you could also work
with government organizations there are
also a lot of Miller technology partners
[Music]
and one bad thing that I could see is
for some reason we are not able to
retain the talent in this country so I
know that all this amazing and PhD
students are coming out of milah but
like the opportunities for them are not
that many even in the case of my spouse
or anything we're finding it hard to
like she's highly qualified but even
then like it's hard to find a job
compared to us
tell her to apply to UBC
so so overall it sounds like you guys
you know in addition to comments we've
heard from the other panels you guys are
particularly emphasizing the freedom
from sort of bean-counting constraints
about research productivity and kind of
collegiality within your departments as
key attractors here thanks for an
informative and entertaining panel I
think we have a few minutes to hear any
questions from the audience that people
in the room might have and let me give a
moment for people to make it to the
microphones if they're gonna do that
yeah please hi yes thanks for their
discussion so we talked a little bit
about multitask learning earlier and I
guess there's two ways to learn a large
amount of tasks you can either learn
them sequentially like us humans we do
or you can learn them simultaneously
just like we're doing right now in ml so
I guess my question is with the former
the problem is you need to relax the
stationary distribution assumption and
with the latter it just seems
impractical to learn a huge amount of
tasks at the same time so I'm wondering
where we should spend our energy we
don't need five people to six people to
answer this but maybe two or three of
you if you have something targeted the
same oh go ahead I can start I think we
like I think both these settings are
valuable right clicks oh so it's not
like one is better than the other and we
should not spend time on the other
setting so especially like let's say you
have a situation where you know all the
tasks like beforehand and like you have
data for training on all these tasks
then training simultaneously like has
been shown to be a better approach
because there's no catastrophic
forgetting and like you can just train a
bigger model with all the tasks and like
as long as there is no conflicting
information between these tasks that you
are going to learn a better multitask
agent but there are also situations
where like you
want to continually learn like where you
have you might start with five tasks but
then like if you want to add a sixth
task in the future like so how would you
add a new task right like so so these
this is these settings also arise like
so so I think we should focus on both
the settings yes so this is a really
interesting question so obviously some
things are sequential in nature right
like I don't learn to hunt before I
learn how to walk like that's that's
that's a weird order but we should also
imagine that our learning systems can
have many many goals and can think about
many many things at once and so in
reinforced learning we typically call
that off call see learning where you do
one thing you learn about many things at
once so you need something like options
to do that or temple abstraction but the
other thing is to think about planning
with the model of the world right
with the model the world the agent can
sit there and it can imagine many many
future scenarios it could be in and
update its policies for four different
situations and so yes there's going to
be things that are sequential just by
the nature of interaction with the world
but we do want to care about
computational efficiency such that we
can leverage any kind of parallelism
that we can thanks let's take another
question now okay thanks very much for
this great discussion I just have a
question regarding the future direction
in machine learning
so I expected to have like more about
understanding deeply what does machine
learning or how does machine learning
work because because most of our
algorithms can be considered as like a
black box we don't understand like
clearly what happens inside this black
box which like avoid a lot of people to
deploy machine learning because we can't
have like real guarantees when deploy a
machine learning in like critical
applications like surgery or robotics or
whatever which have makes some people
claims that maybe machine learning will
be trendy for a few years and then it
will disappear because we can't have
some sort of guarantees for real
application so I would like to hear from
you do you expect like in the near
future we will be able to understand how
the machine learning works and how why
this algorithm works better
the other or like I need to hear your
comment about this it's a great question
who's going to I think um for example if
you want to do send in smaller a
paragraph modeling and you focus on
symbolic reasoning underlying your
understanding quest problem then it's
kind of expanding ability right but it's
not the really explained a machine
learning model but it's explaining the
task that has can be decomposed into
several sub tasks and based on the
output of this sub test and then based
on the output of the other sub task and
then you would eventually to the
automate translation as like this so I
think this is one aspect but not really
the explanation of the machine learning
model itself yeah so I think this is my
partial answer any other thoughts about
the road to explain ability yeah this
question this is something which I
constantly think about or in the past
when we used linguistic representations
of linguistically inspired
representations there used to be an a
component of expandability we know what
the model is able to do but in the
deepening world we lost that but my
hunch is that if we combine deep
learning with reinforcement learning as
some kind of if you are also in using
intermediate representations that can
tell you something about the model we
might be able to fix that problem I'm
not sure yet but we it's not we cannot
guarantee the output that's we can't
guarantee Sellwood so how can we deploy
is a machine learning in real
application and like let people use it
right right yeah I just want to
emphasize the reverse of sometimes we
humans don't have an explanation and
then we do that decision sometimes we do
the decision and then you ask why okay
this is my reason you see if I do the
other decision and
I can also look for those reasons so I
don't think we must have an explanation
although sometimes it could help the
decision I think we have one other very
patient question or elbow surgery do we
have time for one more question
yeah let's end with this one man thanks
thank you
my question is very related I was very
glad to hear that
compositionality is seen as an important
thing and I think that relates a lot to
explain ability so my question is not
whether this is important but maybe how
can we change the CS machine learning
starts and so on education such that the
mathematical theories let's say that
allow us to talk and construct and prove
things about compositional systems are
more present in the toolkit of the
practitioners and other designers
because my suspicion is that we need
more of that stuff and it probably is
not all the stuff that we already teach
so you so your question is about how
teaching should be modified to take
these issues into account yes with with
correlated to what kind of mathematical
two links we might have to represent
need to be represented more great
question okay who wants to go for it
there's a couple of me we haven't heard
from in the questions yet so you know I
mean I'm looking at yeah so that's a
tough question I'm teaching a course
next semester there's still time
yeah I mean so obviously the the field
is groaning under the sheer amount of
technical knowledge that you need to
understand any corner of it so I think
it's really really actually a hard
question because if you need to
understand how to do automatic
differentiation as well as how to you
know prove compactness for a logic
that's a huge amount to ask of anybody
so maybe maybe the answer has to do
with more flexibility in core curricula
for people in AI and machine learning
students I mean I'm sort of have this
issue in in the Linguistics department
we're developing a program in
computational linguistics and of course
I'd like my students to know everything
in deep learning and lambda calculate
and formal logics but that's not really
a plausible you know track but maybe
what we need to be thinking about is
ways for people to piece together
programs that have specializations in
two or three more diverse areas than we
currently see somebody want to take the
last word on how we should respond
educationally to breakthroughs in ml go
for it yes I'm a little bit resistant to
think about change in the CS curriculum
because when you add something in you
have to take things out and already CS
is kind of this field that's not super
well-defined and it's not really clear
what it really is a CS program is
supposed to be about so it's always good
to question what it's about but I think
these these cross discipline
collaborations are probably the way with
right way to go for these kind of
questions rather than changing the
program self because you know every year
we're gonna think of something new it's
like well the students just knew this
thing like stuff it in there somewhere
else and soon will will be missing a lot
see if it did you have something you
were you were burning to say or should
we leave it that house probably
I'd never teach anything yet so so you
can report back next time yes all right
well let's thank all of our panelists
again
[Applause]
you